Hey, everybody, back over here on Zoom webinar.
Been a while since I've been on Zoom webinar.
How's everybody doing, Arnold? How you doing?
Who else is here? Who all is here?
Uh, so look, I'm flying solo.
I know I got a lot of, uh, open claw students on the call.
Yeah. Do we have open clause on the call?
Any any clause on the call? Mike Linley? Yes, there's one.
Yes. Yes. Okay.
So, uh, the reason why I'm doing this, honestly, I'm, I'm,
I'm pretty exhausted.
Uh, we did a three hour call this morning.
Um, so I'm gonna keep this to an hour.
Like I really am gonna keep it to an hour.
I don't have G here, I don't have PNE here.
They are super, super hot and busy.
I'll tell you what they're doing here in a minute.
Um, but I wanted to jump on here
'cause I'm like, okay, you know, we get about 40, 50 people,
um, on our open claw training.
And typically when I do the Friday tech call, it gets up
to about a hundred people.
So this is 50 people that haven't heard from me, uh,
for two weeks because for whatever reason,
they're not aboard the greatest technology ever
to hit our planet, right?
Um, so that's okay,
but I just wanted to make sure I jumped on here
and, uh, let everybody know that there is more
to our world than just open claw right now.
But I also, uh, wanted you guys to understand
that this wasn't just a shiny object.
Like open claw is not just a shiny object,
like it is a very big part of our software, uh,
moving forward.
Does that make sense? It's, it's a very,
very big part of our software moving forward.
So, I, I don't know.
Um, you know, there's some things that I have discovered,
uh, doing, um, uh, you know, this two week training that I,
I didn't know when I got into it.
Just some things that I figured out that you,
you're probably not gonna hear anywhere else.
You're gonna hear it from here first.
Um, and what the future holds,
and this might be good news for some people.
Uh, my belief is that all software is gonna be nearly free.
I, I, I believe that all software, meaning the days
of logging in and, you know, building stuff yourself
and creating links
and everything else, I think
that they're just gonna blow out software
and they kind of have to,
because of how fast you can create software.
Now, like we created a platform yesterday
that we've already submitted
to Facebook, Instagram, and TikTok.
We did it in a day that would've normally taken us
with a really good development team, tops two weeks, right?
So people that have no experience now
can do the vibe coding.
They can build software and everything else.
So what happens, software value is going to crash.
So when values lower, when, when, uh, you know,
things lose their competitiveness, uh, and,
and when things start crashing, then people start
dishing out for free.
And so you're gonna see high
quality software given out for free.
The other thing that you're gonna see if you know anything
about ai, you've been paying attention to Clot or Gemini
or Chad, GBT, or Grok
or any of that stuff, um, is
that the AI models are getting cheaper and cheaper
and cheaper and cheaper, and
that is going to keep happening as well.
So software's gonna turn out to be,
uh, given away pretty cheap.
A lot of it's gonna be free. And then, uh, the AI models
are going to be, um, super cheap as well.
And, and, and there will be, I promise you Mark my word,
there will be, uh, free models.
So how are people gonna make money?
Well, I want you to remember, uh, these
three letters,
and that is, uh, API, okay?
I want you to remember, uh, API
and here's the reason why.
Okay? Let me just see if I can add this
person to a group real quick.
Um, can I add my team?
We have, we have so many people setting up their,
their open clause.
It's not even funny. Um, the APIs, okay?
And, and the reason why is we've proved
for the last two weeks, guys, it's unbelievable.
Unbelievable. First, we had this thing creating Pop links.
Next we had to send creating Lead steps, bridge pages,
finding new sources, writing articles for us on autopilot,
grabbing replays, loading replays,
building full-blown courses.
And today we had to go into Vimeo, grab a video, send
that video to another site that took the video,
analyzed video, cut it up into the clips, then it went
and grabbed those clips, put it into a project center.
I approved it. As soon as it was approved, it sent it over
to another software that's now gonna send it to TikTok,
Instagram, and YouTube.
We did it all today. And that's what I'm trying to tell you.
The APIs are what you will pay for.
And mark my word, I've never seen this
before, but I know it's coming.
There will be a silver, gold,
and platinum version of the API
and that will be the new world we live in.
You, you will literally say,
go build this page for me.
Go build this funnel, write this email,
and that's gonna happen.
And you will pay, it will be more expensive.
The software will be more expensive than
what you're paying today
because of its abilities with APIs, okay?
And, and what we're seeing with platforms like Open Claw
and Open Claw is not the last one.
It's not the only one.
There's, there's gonna be lots of them.
Manis is right behind them.
There's all these different
platforms, but this is the future.
This is, this is what it's gonna take.
So I've been telling, um, my mastermind in my communities
and everything that, look, this is a shiny object.
Do what I'm doing, showcase it.
Show people what you're doing.
Build a big list, build an audience,
capitalize that audience.
Um, but I, I'm, I'm here to tell you that everything
that you have known has changed.
So it's gonna come down to, and this is where our focus is.
Obviously the newsletter is still our, our goal,
our goal, our holy grail.
It will, it will always be.
And, and now what we figured out is we figured out how
to take open claw and build separate agents in there.
And each one of those agents can be a different city.
So I, I can have a, um, an agent that takes care of, of,
of West Valley shoutouts.
I can have an agent that take care of Henderson Shoutouts.
I can have an agent that take care of West Valley shoutouts.
And those things can build up, uh, you know,
every single day, every single week.
Um, hold on a minute, can you make
me an admin for a minute?
Um, uh, so those things are gonna build up.
And then, and then you're gonna have this amazing
opportunity to go out there,
and I still believe it sell out for millions of dollars.
But now on top of that, you get to say to the buyer, oh,
and by the way, you don't need employees.
You don't need staff, you don't need VAs or anything else.
We have a, uh, especially trained AI that,
that goes out there and finds the content and, and writes it
and make sure that you get to Google and YouTube
and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And it just, it. And so people are are learning about
that opportunity of, of taking all this open claw stuff or,
or, you know, whatever we use
and, uh, be able to go out there and do that, right?
So it, it's incredible.
And, and the other thing that, um, is absolutely incredible
that blew everybody's mind is, I think it was yesterday,
we went and trained this thing to, uh, I, I, I,
I am able to do a short, uh, short command.
So like, uh, what you'll find, um,
in this workshop is you can do four slash pop link,
you know, ask you what's your pop link four slash uh,
you know, lead step four slash bridge,
page four slash email.
And then we did one called four slash uh, reactivation.
And what it says is, it says,
how many people are you looking to reactivate?
Well, I wanna activate, uh, a hundred thousand, okay?
And do you wanna be, uh, mild, normal, or aggressive?
Oh, I wanna be aggressive. Alright, cool.
So here's the schedule. It says I'm gonna send, uh,
50 emails the first day,
and on the second day, I'm gonna send a hundred an hour.
And, uh, on the next day, I'm gonna send 200 an hour.
On the next day I'm gonna send 400 an hour,
and that's where I'm gonna cap out.
And I'm gonna send 400 an hour, eight hours a day,
3,200 emails in a day.
And I'm gonna do it till we get all the way till the end
of the reactivation.
And then one of my students turned around
and said, well, uh,
can we validate the emails before we send 'em out?
We're like, sure. So then we went
and tied it into a service called Email List Verify.
So now you load the list, it gets the list, it sends it
to email list, verify email list, verify cleans the email,
sends it back to open claw.
Open claw, takes it, puts it in database,
and pulls out a certain number every single time
and drops it into the workflow.
But guys, I had employees that were hired
to do just that.
Do, do you guys understand this right now?
I got VAs from the Philippines.
I got three of 'em that are freaking out on me.
Uh, somebody sent a message last night saying,
Chad, do I still have a job?
'cause this thing does everything you've trained me how
to do, right?
It is the most amazing opportunity,
and it is 18 months ahead of the rest of the world.
And I've let my audience know, uh, and, and,
and I've done everything I can to, uh, teach 'em how
to do this so that they can go build this
opportunity out for other people.
We're getting ready to hire, uh, 12 UNLV interns.
Uh, they will be working under me.
Uh, they will be doing open claw installs
and everything else because we have that big of a demand.
Um, on top of that,
my buddy Nick is gonna be speaking on
stages all around the world.
He was just speaking to TEDx this morning, uh,
introducing this technology
and then bringing those build outs to me.
And he wanted me to go hit the stage, uh, with him.
But I'm not gonna do that
because, uh, I just need to be behind the computer
and I actually feel, uh, really, really good, uh, when I'm
behind the computer, right?
So, um, this is the thing. What does all this mean?
We now understand, uh, what this means for,
uh, it's not letting me add it.
Hmm, not letting me.
Uh, we now understand what this means
for our software, okay?
Does everybody get that? I wanna make sure
everybody is getting this right.
Now, on a scale of one out of 10, how many of you understand
that we're just trying to automate our software?
And, um, I'm not gonna mention names, but I'm watching.
It's so funny, I'm watching other videos
and I'm watching Threads where people are trying
to take certain platforms
and they're trying to do what we're doing,
and they're like, the damn API docs are too complicated.
They're all over the place. They're spread everywhere.
Yeah, they, the API docs can't be read. I get it.
They will catch up with us,
but right now we have the smoking gun
and we're having a ball with it.
We're having a lot of fun, right? So here's the good news.
The good news is this,
and I'll show you, I'll show you some telegram.
How many of you who has not been a part of that class,
type in the chat, yes or no?
Have you been in the class? Yes or no?
Yes. No, yes. No, no, no, no. Okay. A lot of nos. All right.
Um, so it's about 60 40 all.
So I will show, um, you what's happening.
Uh, I'll also show you that, uh, we're looking
to go out there at bare minimal for companies.
Uh, Nick's gonna go on stage,
and we're gonna have a bare minimal $7,000 build out bare
minimal with what I'm about to show you.
And everybody in the class has been learning
to do these things and learning to code and everything else.
But, so now that we understand that you're just gonna go
and send a message that says, Hey, build me a pop link.
Hey, build me a lead step. Hey, build me a funnel.
Now that you understand all that, uh, what we're doing now,
because there was a huge shift two weeks ago.
Two weeks ago, everything changed.
That's where I jumped aboard this thing.
And, uh, everything up to this point, guys,
has been reactive ai.
And what that means is people are playing with chat, GBT,
it's writing copy, writing headlines.
They're, I saw some people are making
figurines of themselves.
And I saw one class in the morning where everybody learned
how to make a little teddy bear in themselves.
And great, that's called playing around, right?
But the AI is no longer reactive, okay?
It's no longer you enter something,
you enter a prompt and it gives you an answer.
No, it's proactive now.
So it's not only, not only does it have eyes, ears, arms,
and legs and performing actions,
but on top of that, it can anticipate problems
and it can fix the problems as it goes along.
Does that make sense to you guys?
That changed about, uh, just a little under a month ago.
I mean, overnight, it changed, guys, everything in the world
of software, SaaS, everything,
it all changed really, really fast.
And we just happened to be one of the early adopters.
And I mean, I, I, uh,
was talking my mastermind the other day,
and I'm like, yeah, we, um, I,
I've been screaming from the rooftops.
I've been blowing up my wall, what we're doing, right?
I've been p*****g a lot of people off too.
Um, but we were one of the early adopters.
But here's the great news guys.
Not only were we one of the early adopters on, uh,
open Claw, but what if I told you that, uh,
probably within a week, it's just a matter of me being able
to sit down and finally have a minute.
Probably within a week, we're gonna have 20, 25 new layouts
for Letterman, which means when you go
to your news directory, uh, it's gonna look like CNN news.
It's gonna look like Fox News, it's gonna look like Yahoo.
It's gonna look like, because we're building these beautiful
templates, um, and we're able to plug it into our software.
So not only Letterman, also pop links.
I will never, ever give up my lead steps or bridge pages.
They make the most money out of everything in my business.
Okay? Well, I told 'em though, I said, man,
when I create a pop link, I wanna know, um,
does it have, uh, is this the group on?
Is this the group? I wanna know?
Is it, uh, uh, does it need
to be a traditional marketing feel?
Does it need to be new age?
Does it need to have like gradients?
Does it, uh, need to feel like social media?
Like, what does this page need to feel like?
And, and now that I've done that, AI will go
and create those templates
before we hard coded it with certain colors
and fonts and everything else.
Well, now AI is gonna go create all those things.
So we're gonna have a brand new look for a pop links.
The other thing that we're doing right now, um,
is we're taking member because everything has changed,
and we're gonna have it to where you type in a prompt,
and yes, it creates you a full blown sales page.
We tried to do this before, and AI wasn't where it needed
to be, but now things are a lot different.
It's gonna create that full blown sales page,
and then you're gonna be able to go in
and you're gonna be able to make the changes
to the elements and everything else.
So I'm really trying to beef up our platform,
especially now that I know
everything can be ran from something like Open Cloth.
Does that make sense? The other thing you're gonna see, um,
probably Monday or Tuesday, is when you log into the,
the Global Control Center, uh, you're gonna see
that you can just instantly click
and you can get into Mint Bird, you can get into Page Brow,
you can get into Letterman, you can get into quiz forma.
If you have a Course Brow, you can get into Course Brow.
You can, you can get into any
of our software from Global Control.
Now we're starting there.
But then what's gonna happen is we're gonna go into the
actual software, and we're gonna have
that little widget there where it opens up.
You can access all the software from there as well.
All right? Um, I know a lot
of people are creating little apps to help you with images
and mind mapping and, and this and that and everything else.
Well, guess what? We're gonna do the same thing.
Here's the difference. I'm not looking
to make money off anybody.
I'm gonna use it to build our audience,
to build our community.
And then people come into our main software
and they come into our mastermind.
That's where we make our money. So all the apps
that you see out there that are being sold, uh,
we will build even better.
And we're going to just include them inside of GC so
that they work with all of our software.
Does that make sense to everybody?
So I'll teach you how to do that stuff.
I'm the guy that takes a complicated
process and simplifies it.
Everybody tells me that I get it. We will do that stuff.
But for right now, before I teach anybody to do anything,
I need everybody to know that we're not only doing it,
but we're the leaders in what we're doing, right?
So we will go out there, we're already doing it.
Uh, we built an app last night.
We're waiting to get approval from Facebook,
Instagram, and TikTok.
It's one that I've wanted for a while
because I wanted the articles to automatically syndicate
to Facebook, Instagram, TikTok, YouTube, everything else.
So we built the software last night, we laid it all out, uh,
and now we're submitting it for approval from Facebook,
Instagram, and TikTok.
And if that happens, articles will automatically be
submitted to all your social media.
But on top of that, opening Claw is gonna be able
to access this software, a software
that's gonna cost you $20 a month.
If you go anywhere else, we're not
gonna charge for it, right?
We're just gonna open up the API key
and people are gonna be able
to syndicate out to those platforms.
Does that make sense? AI Bought Studio also go under, uh,
the knife also going under a complete, uh, new revamp
and everything else with the AI bots
that you can deploy on your site and everything else.
Trust me, when I say guys, the team is very, very dedicated
to this new build out, to this new technology.
Uh, I have gotten rid of team members this week.
I've gotten rid of, uh, we had an SSL issue over a really,
really stupid mistake.
Uh, that developer, quite frankly, refused to adapt, uh,
refuse to, uh, embrace the new technology.
Did not want to pivot.
Had been with me for 15 years, and I gave warning
after warning after warning.
And I finally said, you know what?
I, I have a lot of respect for you.
I like you as a person, but this is not working out anymore.
So I've been making those tough changes as well,
and I've been letting go of the people
that were holding our company back.
And so now the company is super,
super excited to move forward.
We are embracing the technology, we're embracing the new.
Um, and we know for the next 18 months,
it's gonna be really, really good.
And we're gonna use those 18 months to go out there
and build a very, very strong brand,
build a very, very big audience.
And then, quite frankly, guys,
after 18 months, uh, I don't know what the world's gonna do.
I don't know what the marketplace is gonna do if you're not
embracing AI and if you're not learning how to manage it.
That's what I'm telling my VAs.
I said, you know, instead of you being scared,
why don't you say thank you, thank you
for giving the opportunity to teach
what is gonna wipe out the Philippines.
Like, thank you for giving me the
opportunity to get ahead of it.
Thank you for teaching me that I need
to be the one running this, that I get to keep my job,
whereas the rest of the country
loses their fricking position.
Like, that's how you need to start looking at this thing.
But I'm gonna say the same thing for you guys.
In 18 months, it will be scary.
Uh, white collar wiped out, VAs wiped out,
and it'll start going into blue collar as well.
Now, I'm not trying to scare anybody,
but I think you should start paying attention.
I really, really think you need to start paying attention.
And the people that are gonna do really well during this
are people who embrace the new and follow my lead
and know how to get engagement, know how
to go out there on their wall, know how to create hooks,
know how to build communities, know how
to get out there and take care of their members.
Those are the people that are gonna thrive.
Everybody else I am scared have to death, honest to God,
like I, I know as a conspiracy theory,
but I truly believe that the government wants, I I think
that they did a test with COVID.
I think they wanna send everybody back to their room
and, uh, set everybody on, on a set pension.
I believe that's what's gonna happen.
I, I don't believe that there's
gonna be enough jobs in the world.
And, and I truly believe
that everybody's gonna be sent back to their home.
COVID was a test.
And, uh, people are gonna be on a sad pension.
That's what I think is happening, right?
Without getting political
or anything else, that's what's going to happen.
That's the writings on the wall.
And I'm telling you right now, I freaking refuse it.
I refuse it for myself. I refuse it for my spouse.
I refuse it for my kids.
Connie's coming to me with the same thing.
She's showing me videos about things that are,
that are doing hair extensions
and curling, hair and coloring.
And I'm like, yeah, yeah. I don't know.
It like, to me, I would think that somebody
that sits in your chair wants to sit in your chair
'cause they want to have a conversation with you.
But you know, this robot comes in and, and you pay, uh, 25%.
I don't know. I don't know.
I, I don't know what the future holds.
All I know is I know there's a hidden agenda here,
and I refuse to play.
And I think that you guys have 18 months to figure that out.
And you should refuse to play too, right?
You should start playing ball.
And if you've been waiting for things to be perfect,
or you're like, Hey, you know,
I couldn't finish this course,
but it was really, well, guess what?
Learn open claw.
'cause I gave open Claw a folder
and said, here, go build a course.
And it went, grabbed all the videos,
transcribed all the videos, wrote the descriptions,
wrote the short, long description, created a goal block,
built a whole course in less than a minute.
You guys wanna know what that cost me. I've done it twice.
The first time it cost me less than 30 cents.
The second time, it didn't even cost me 2 cents.
I don't even think it was a penny. Seriously, that's
where things are going.
And what you don't want to do,
like I'm telling you right now, how many
of you feel like you got behind?
Be honest with me. Who got behind in this AI thing?
Who got behind with the vibe coding?
Who got behind with the gamma, who got behind
with the chat bot who got behind?
Type in the chat. Let me know.
'cause I'm gonna wake you up right now.
Who got behind on those things? I'm trying to help you.
I got nothing to sell you today. Who got behind?
Look, everybody's saying, uh, Glenna says she got behind.
Paul got behind. Robin got behind. Brian got behind.
Ronald got behind. Eloise got behind. Ron got behind.
Yeah, look at all the people that got behind.
And what happens when you get behind? Be honest with me.
What happens? Do you ever catch up?
Do you ever catch up? Honestly, no.
You just keep telling yourself you're too far behind.
It's too late. It's too late.
Some of you will try to catch up. Most people won't.
Most people will tell themselves, oh, you know what?
I missed the boat on that. And what happens?
You start getting further and further and further behind.
Guys, you don't have that option right now.
Do you understand? There's, there's no chance for you
to get behind right now.
That's not an option anymore.
I'm, I'm gonna tell you right now. And I, I told them, I, I,
I said years ago, it's not time to pay attention to AI yet.
I saw what it was doing with chat, GPT and Grok and Gemini,
and I saw what it was doing in Letterman.
I saw how it was integrating with our, our software.
And I started getting excited when the API started.
But I kept telling everybody, Nope, nope, nope, nope.
All all the world is doing is building a brain.
It's building a brain. It's building a brain. That's it.
It's building a brain. When they take that brain
and they put that brain on a robot that has arms and legs
and, and can move, and can walk and can think
and hear, then you pay attention.
Guess it's here, guys. It's here right now.
This robot is not one
that's physical like I was talking about before.
It's all on a computer, but it's here
and it is doing those things.
And so it's not too late.
You get off this call, you need to start paying attention.
You need to go to my wall, need
to start watching some of those videos.
I've been emailing out clips.
I'm, I'm trying, I've been sick too.
But I've been doing all these things
to keep everybody posted, okay?
It's not too late. The train is here, the doors are open.
And I need you guys to attention
right now is the perfect time to get on board.
And what's so incredible about this,
if you get on board right now,
you are actually further ahead of everybody else
that's been going to stupid AI summits every six months
and watching webinars and hopping on live feeds.
And every, none of that mattered, guys.
It was all child's play. It was all child's play.
Now it matters. I'm telling you right now. Now it matters.
And I would not have gone and, um, taken all my stuff.
I stopped everything midway.
I said, stop everything that you're doing.
I said, you go build out gc.
You go build out Min Bird, you go build out page route.
You go build out quiz format. You go build out Letterman.
I stopped everybody and told them all
to go build out our APIs so
that we could have open claw building articles,
building links, building pages.
If you were on this call, type in the chat.
Let me know who, who's been on these calls.
Am I telling the truth? That's what we did.
And because it was urgent,
it was super, super urgent, guys.
Okay? Now, I'm gonna tell you, um, here in a couple weeks,
I believe, uh, I'm gonna run 2.0 version of that workshop.
I'm gonna do it all over again from the very start.
I'm gonna start with a clean install.
Bring our software in, turn on API keys,
teach you how to create skills.
I'm gonna do it all over again for another 14 days straight.
That's what we've been doing. We did day 12 today.
I'm gonna do it all over again, okay?
And I told everybody that went to the first one to get
to come to the second one, all right?
Um, and here's the reason why.
I think it's the most important thing for you guys to learn.
I really, truly do.
You have to pay attention if you don't.
If if you do, first of all,
you have a great opportunity for 18 months.
You get to go out there and
you can do this for other people.
And trust me, I even told everybody on my class,
if you get a client, we will install it for you
and we will onboard that client for you.
That's how much I want you to succeed, right?
Some people are charging $1,500 just
for the install alone apps app.
Sumo is charging $1,500 for the install loan. Guys.
We did over 300 installs
or whatever, approaching 400 for free.
We did 'em for free. We're getting ready to do more.
We ran into some server problems, right?
We ran outta servers. But we're getting ready to do more.
We got a plan that's going into play right now.
Um, but yeah, you got to pay attention to this.
You have to. And for 18 months, it's a gold rush.
It's a gold rush for you to build a brand.
It's a gold rush for you to go out there
and build this technology.
Everybody else is still talking about Chad Chip T uh,
if you pay attention to Facebook,
people are having trouble installing it.
And guys, we're, we're actually doing things.
I think I'm the only one in the business
that's actually doing things right,
and the business hates me for it.
Oh my God, there's so much smack happening behind my back.
People are messaging me.
They're like, dude, you are not liked you doing those free
installs, and you actually doing these things.
People are hating on you. I'm like, I don't care.
I'm out for my members. I don't care.
I don't need no more partners. I don't need the stages.
I don't need nothing, man.
I'm here for my members and I'm gonna protect them.
'cause this is a great, not only opportunity,
but it is a great message for you guys to hear right now.
It truly is. And the people that don't hear that, the people
that don't embrace it, the people
that just think it's another cha bt thing,
or another grok thing or another assistant thing.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Nothing like that. Guys. Everything changed.
The, the, the marketing world, the entrepreneurial world,
the software world, everything changed,
but nobody knows it yet.
I'm, I'm giving you guys the design word.
I'm deep in the trenches doing this thing every day.
Everything changed. And so these are good changes
for the next 18 months.
And then afterwards, I don't know what happens.
I don't, I'm, I'm truly sad for people. I, I really am.
I, I ask Connie all the time,
I'm like, what are people gonna do?
What are they gonna do? They don't even know.
They don't even know what's coming. What are they gonna do?
What are they going to do? Seriously? I don't know.
I, I don't know. Uh, right now there's companies
that are taking white collar workers
and they're teaching them how to run the stuff
that I'm teaching my students.
Can you make sure that other phone gets here?
Will you tell her, please? Oh, the approach, okay.
Um, uh, and it is like, I don't know.
My, my heart is my, I, I'm, I'm, I'm concerned with that.
I'm really concerned about that. Uh, really concerned.
I, I don't, I'm, I'm not, I'm not sleeping.
But I'm gonna tell you right now, the other thing that I'm,
I'm, I'm concerned with is I have not one,
but I have two students
that are facing their final hours in life that have been
with me for over 15 years.
And I, I, I, I, I, I just, I don't know how to accept
that when I'm used to seeing somebody on a call,
like every week when I did the round table every week,
when I did the, the, you know, like every week.
Like, like, it's just a reminder of how,
uh, short life is.
You know, it, it, it really is.
I, and, and, you know, I lost Herbert
Green this year and everything else.
Like, those things really stop me from sleeping.
Like the, the reason, the reason why I bill
what I do, uh, build what I build.
And the reason why I do what I do is
'cause I want people to succeed.
And I, I want people to have a, a, a a great, you know,
stress feeding life and not go through what I went
through at one point, you know?
And it's like when we start losing those students, I'm, I'm,
I'm totally lost for words.
And so it's not that I'm insensitive or anything else,
but I bury myself in work
because I don't know what else to do.
I don't know what to do. I don't know what to say.
Does that make sense to you guys?
It's not that I'm insensitive, it's not, Chad,
you've been hustling and everything else.
You haven't stopped and said anything.
No, I don't know what to say.
I don't know what to say, you know? So I just stay busy.
I stay busy, and I just try
to put out the best message I can, right?
And the same message that they heard for a long time.
But, uh, things are, things are different guys.
Do you, do you understand that things are different?
Like things are different today. They're different.
Like, I've been in this business since 1998.
I've never been more concerned than I am today.
Am I excited about what's happening?
Honestly, if I could be honest with you, no, no.
I, I wish things were like they were 15 years ago.
I don't like this. I, I don't, I don't like the fact that,
uh, people with no experience whatsoever can come
to my level of creating software and everything.
No, I, I don't like it.
That's always been, that's always been my secret formula.
That's always been my superpowers.
I train myself to do that, right? No, that's scary to me.
And every JV I'm talking to, every affiliate I'm talking,
they all have the same concerns.
They're all very, very scared.
And we're all gonna have to pivot.
And all I can say, the only thing I do know
is while the going is good, this is
where the momentum starts.
Does that make sense? This is like stealing candy
from a baby right now.
Do you understand? Like if you've been, uh, if,
if you've been scared to put together an offer,
if you've been scared to sell, if you've been scared
to put yourself out there, uh,
this is gonna be the very best time for you to do it.
The next 18 months are a gold rush. They are a gold rush.
While the balance is happening, while the world is,
is getting used to these changes, it okay?
It, it is going to be a gold rush.
Do you guys understand that right now,
pe people are gonna make a lot of money, uh,
collecting from business owners.
They're gonna make a lot of money building their brand.
They're gonna build huge lists.
They're gonna build huge communities.
Like those things are gonna happen to the people
that are smart and realize that you need to be working
with this every single day.
You need to work on this every single day
for the next 18 months.
It's 18 months of your life. You gotta do it, folks.
You gotta do it. And if you can get that momentum going,
if you can grow bigger than you ever have
before, if you can do things that you've always wanted
to do, but for whatever reason it just wasn't right,
or you were in your head, or you're gonna wait
for this weekend, or whatever the excuse,
if you can just get that momentum going, then when
that 18 months ends,
you just keep the momentum going.
And it ain't gonna be like stealing
candy from a baby anymore.
But you use these 18 months to build those skills.
Does that make sense? You use these 18 months
to build those skills to get you through the new norm
that's about to hit us.
And I'm telling you, man, it is going to be something else.
The only other thing I compare it to, the only thing
that has ever been that drastic to me was the pandemic.
That's it. And, and the pandemic.
If you think about, did you guys have
to pivot during the pandemic?
Did you have to make changes during the pandemic?
Yeah, of course you did. That was massive.
Those were massive changes.
And the freaking pandemic guys is a fraction
of what I'm telling you right now.
It's a fraction,
and I truly believe it's gonna be feast or famine.
And I truly believe
they're gonna send us home with a pension.
That's the goal, and that's the control.
I know that's getting into conspiracy stuff,
but that's, that's what I believe is happening.
It's the only thing that makes sense.
It's the only thing, right?
And, uh, I, I, I would hope
that you can arm yourself in your own home
and know how to build a community
and know how to build a list and know how to put out hooks
and know how to build an offer and,
and recognize when something's a shiny object.
And, and know how to deploy those things,
and know how to build pages and, and links and,
and sales pages, and, and keep your articles going.
And, and, you know, one day sell out for a million dollars
and it doesn't even, it doesn't even affect you.
Does that make sense? Are, are y'all starting
to get this message right now?
Are y'all, look, this is what happened.
My birthday was January 24th. You guys saw that.
I went into a big time re-engagement mode,
and I used Hustle 2.0.
I, I open up a newsletter
because I'm always watching newsletters
to see what's going on.
And, uh, there was a mention of Open Claw.
I was like, what the heck is this?
And I jumped on and I found one single video
and I watched it, and I said, oh my God, it's here.
And I, I went into Zoom,
and on January 26th, two days later, uh, it was
that morning, I posted that video and I told G
and I told Aya, I said, I want you guys to watch this.
I will meet with you at nine 30.
Usually I meet with him at nine. I met with him at nine 30.
I said, guys, first of all, I don't want you
to be threatened with what I'm about to tell you,
but this thing is gonna do everything that I want you guys
to do that we're dropping the ball on.
Meaning, uh, setting up the webinar replays, uh,
or the webinar descriptions, going
and grabbing the replays, going
and putting 'em in course route.
Um, you know, every, everything that we do,
everything we do in our business, writing emails,
doing workflows, firing tags, the contacts,
like re-engagement.
I said, this thing is gonna do everything.
And it was like, okay, well, where does that leave us?
No, no, no. I'm keeping you guys, I need you guys.
I need you on the calls with me.
That's what makes you guys make me valuable,
because you're here fixing problems in real time.
I want you on more calls.
I don't want you worried about, uh, you know,
is the replay loaded?
Is the course done? Is the goal block done?
I don't, I don't, I, no, I want you guys here with me.
You're too valuable. I want the AI to do those things.
They said, are you sure it's gonna do everything?
I said, it's gonna do everything. And
guys, I'm not kidding you.
I went, uh, that weekend, uh, I had g set it up for me.
It was a Friday. I went to bed
and, um, I I, I went to bed
and I, I was, uh, laying in bed.
Uh, there we go. Let me add this group.
And, uh, Connie was right next to me
and I said, uh, if I give you the login,
um, can you go
into Page Sprout?
And I gave it the login and it says, I'm logged in now.
It did it during the, it did it with the browser.
And I looked at her shoulder, I said, look, it logged in.
She's like, oh no, it's just saying that.
I just sat there looking at it
and it, I could see it was typing.
And then all of a sudden it said, I'm logged in.
I see dashboard, I see pop links, I see pages. I see.
It was telling me everything, uh, that it showed, it,
it, it was telling me everything.
And it showed on the side menu.
I was like, look, it's actually logged in.
And then it asked me, it said, what do you want me to do?
I was like, what do you mean? He's like,
do you want me to create a pop link?
I'm like, I guess so. And I said, yes.
And it went and it created a pop link.
And it came back to me and I said, oh my God.
And then I obsessed that Saturday, I cracked the code.
Sunday, I sent out an email saying, we're gonna be starting
a, uh, shadow intensive where you're going
to watch me show up for the next two weeks,
and here's what I'm gonna build.
And it was everything that I told
my team we're gonna automate.
And I knew that if I had not put myself in the box,
not had it where I, I, I invited my mastermind
but not had it where paid members were there
watching us do this thing, then I would never get it done.
And so we have showed up every single day.
And from that guys,
I'm like a leader in this thing right now,
building a huge audience, got everybody's attention,
and what we're doing, we're 18 months ahead of everybody.
And it's, it's, it's absolutely incredible.
And you guys know, I'm not one to promote AI products.
Uh, I wasn't excited about ai, not until now,
because it removes all of your limitations.
How many of you knew that if you set up a
lead step, you could build a list?
Who knew that? Who knew the marketers love language
with the headline that I taught you for years?
And I go open up our account
and show you, you know, this thing got a 70% conversion
and we brought in 600 people.
And who knew that? Yes or no?
Who knew that you could go out there and create lead steps
and you could create traffic
campaigns with solos and stuff like that.
You could create lead steps. And uh,
I think your voice is duplicating, really.
Uh, you could build lead steps and build a list.
Everybody knew that, right?
That's the point of the lead step.
It would do two steps at once. Absolutely incredible.
It's still incredible. We're gonna make it more incredible.
Or Bridge Pages. Who knew
that you could create a bridge page and it's more personal,
and you put a video on there and,
and when you do, you could go mail
your list to the bridge page.
And then we, we set it up later where you can click the link
and, and tag and you start hot listing.
Who knew that? Everybody on this call knew that.
So why weren't you doing it? Why weren't you doing it?
Because there was a technical challenge there, right?
There was a technical obstacle.
You still, as easy as I tried to make it,
you still told yourself, oh, it's, it's, it's hard.
It's too hard. I don't know how to do this.
I'm not gonna create the right headline.
Nobody's gonna enter their email address.
Whatever the reason was, guys, it's removed,
intimidated, it's removed.
Do you, do you understand that?
Let me, let me show you what I mean.
Look, I'm gonna share my screen
'cause I, I want you all primed for the next one, uh,
when it comes up, okay?
So look, I'm gonna show you a couple things.
I'm over here inside of Telegram right now, okay?
Um, I, I don't even know what I'm looking at.
I'm looking at Team Pacino right now. Hold on a minute.
Let me just do this, uh, real quick.
Um, what is your telegram again?
Yeah, so, uh, I'm over here inside of,
uh, team Pacino.
And you can see these are all team
members that I have over here.
Is everybody seeing this right now?
All of these team members,
I just wanna make sure you're seeing the right screen.
All of these team members guys can talk
to the bot, all of them.
The name of my bot is Pacino.
So you can see that, uh, this was a demo earlier.
It found three accounts, TikTok, YouTube, Instagram, right?
Lo loaded the video, published a video, right?
But, but I can come over here
and you'll, you'll see this is all stuff we do
during the workshop, okay?
Today was really, really hard.
Uh, 'cause we took a video, cut it up into clips, right?
And then yeah, we, we were like it, it went
and created these nine clips,
this other software and gave us a score.
And um, yeah, today was pretty hard.
But if I come up here, uh, a little bit higher
before today, uh, yeah, it went
and built this, this, uh, dashboard for us today
that it actually uses itself.
So it not only builds software like you are saying, okay,
but we can do that with Vibe coding.
Yeah, but the difference is this thing builds a software
that it uses.
Do you understand? It builds a software that it uses.
Um, so this is like one of the pieces
of software it built today, uh,
and it built it within minutes, right?
So this is all stuff that we're teaching, uh,
during this workshop, right?
But I'm gonna show you something else too.
And this is where the real money comes from.
So this is all the work today.
And normally it's not this hard.
Once you have trained it, uh, you're kind of done
with it, right?
But this one was a complicated build out today, okay?
But let me see if I can get over here
where it loaded the replay this
morning so I can show you guys.
Uh, hold on a second.
And this is all done for pennies on the dollar
because most of the time, uh,
we use a model called Kimmy 2.5.
Okay? Um, so this is where it learned the API,
you guys will learn about all this stuff.
You can take any API, you can make it work
with this software, um, and you think it's super techy,
but I've done everything I can to make it really,
really easy for you guys.
Um, but let's see what this is. Okay? We're getting close.
This was all the work from today.
It was a three hour workshop,
but I'm telling you it was game changer, man.
And what I'll do is I'll cut out some clips from today's
replay 'cause it's only for the members.
And I'll send you guys a bridge page.
So when you get that bridge page,
you're gonna wanna watch it, okay?
Um, and I'll give you something else
that you can work on in the meantime.
Date. Okay? So now look at this.
So Hannah, this is where it started this morning.
Hannah jumped in
and she said forward slash replay.
And it said, Hey, I'll help you out the replay.
Give me the Vimeo URL.
So she gave it this URL
and it said, okay, let me go get the video details.
So this is the bot, this is Pacino talking.
And um, you can see here
it says day 12.
Uh, and she said, you choose the topic based on the call.
It couldn't find a transcript, but it created it.
Anyways, not only did it go created inside a course sprout,
guys, it created a title, it created a short description,
the long description, and placed the video in there.
And then it created a goal block as well.
Are you guys seeing this right now?
Type in the chat. Let me know if you're seeing this
crazy good right now.
What's awesome about this?
And let me just add, uh,
let me just add him in here real quick, okay?
Uh, I'll tell you the reason why, uh, added you to,
uh, telegram.
Uh, you guys know, uh, Karthik has a launch guy,
uh, uh, named, uh, Neil Napier.
You guys know Neil Napier?
So, uh, we built this bot for, uh, Neil Napier.
And uh, what's happening is,
this is his whole team over here and his, his partner Steven
or whatever, and I just added G in here,
and G's gonna set it up to where his whole team
can talk to this bot.
Now guys, this is going to be a $7,000 service
that Nikki Co is gonna be selling from stage.
So you can see over here, we have it here, uh, over here.
Are you leaving it again over here?
This is Nick's company.
And you can see that we have our VAs in here, Hannah,
we have Zi, uh, and we also have, uh, Keith, right?
These are all VAs.
And you can see, uh, reengagement campaign, uh,
total contacts 1500, sent 849 remaining, 654.
Um, and you can see that, uh,
PNE is getting day three to start.
See, this day three started hour in progress rate 200,
it's gonna go pull those contacts out of its bank
and automatically load it in a workflow.
Now, this is great news for you
because how many of you was smart enough
to get the Brian Anderson deal?
Who got the Brian Anderson deal? Just, just curious.
Okay, hang out with me.
'cause I'm gonna tell you right now, uh,
we have figured out a source to get the business owners
and, uh, we have figured out
how we're gonna do the same exact workflow
and we are going to automate it
like what Brian Anderson's teaching and,
and, uh, what you paid for with Brian Anderson.
And they did a, they did a webinar the other day
and I was super excited for it.
What you basically paid for is the ability to send leads to
his company and then they get on the phone
and they close the deal for you.
Did that make sense to everybody?
And I, and I did everything I could
to make sure everybody knew how incredible that deal was.
'cause you can send 'em as many leads as you want,
and they're gonna close deals.
And last year they sold like 9 million.
They did like $9 million in affiliate commissions.
I'm like, I am all over that thing. Well, guess what guys?
We are going to automate it with what we're doing here,
with what we're doing with gc with
what you're doing right here on the screen, okay?
So this whole thing about taking open claw
and putting it into something like Telegram
and having all of your team members here is big money.
And the reason why is you see that I just went
and added G in here.
Well, now g has to go do some custom coding inside
of Open Claw to get this bot to respond to everybody.
Does that make sense? How many
of you're starting to get this right now?
So not only did we do it with Neil Napier,
not only have we done it with Nikki Coe,
but on top of that, if I come over here, you're gonna see
that this is Karthik's bot
and Karthik has his whole team over here.
So the name of my bot is Pacino.
The name of Nick's bot is Mario after like Mario Brothers.
And the name of Karthik's bot is Sanjeet.
And we're doing the same exact thing with Karthik.
We're over here trying to get all of his contacts moved
to gc, um,
because he realizes
that autoresponders are a scam, right?
Um, hold on a second.
Let me just see if I can do this real quick.
Can I make him an admin? Hold on just a minute, guys.
Let me see. I don't know if I can do that.
Uh, can I make you an admin?
Hold on just a second here, guys. Uh, promote to admin.
Okay, there we go. Uh, hold on.
Promote to admin, edit admin rights. Okay, there we go.
Now he can do it. All right, so the,
this whole thing over here, doing this as a team
or whatever, right?
Big money guys, big, big money.
But let me just kind of do a quick
demonstration for you real quick.
Um, I'm gonna do this forward slash pop wink.
I'll just give you, uh, uh,
some quick samples real quick, right?
So you can see it's typing up here, okay?
And by the way, I'm talking to it by myself right now.
If I wanted to come in here to the team room,
I could come into the team room.
Okay? So I'm just giving you guys a, a preview for those
of you that have not seen this technology
or what it's doing.
Um, but let me see what it's doing quick.
What do you need to do? Create a pop link list, pop links,
edit pop link, create bridge page.
So I'm just gonna go ahead
and say, um, let me find, let me,
let me get this for you guys.
I'll give you something, uh, that will get you going.
Um, when you join the workshop, this is one
of the steps you're gonna do.
Uh, I built this this morning.
Is there anybody that would like to have this?
So this is going to prepare you for this AI based off of
what I've been trying to teach you guys, okay?
And so you can see that it's pretty interesting
because I've been talking to it so much.
It's interesting how much it knows me, right?
It created this philosophy. Don't wait for perfect.
Just start create your own system, method,
process strategy, secret or formula.
Scream it from the rooftops. You have to get attention.
Always build a community. The hook is everything.
Put as many hooks in the water as you can.
Do the things you know you need to do. Crack the code.
Always remember the MVP with everything you do.
As amazing as AI and technology is today.
You still have to, you still have to have something to sell
and somebody to sell to each one.
Teach one focus on the money with the desire
to provide a transformational value in the lives of others.
If you're not making the money you want,
you're not asking for it.
And the CEO mindset oversee, don't get stuck.
I didn't, I, this is not me, everything else is me,
but this one's done at Washington.
So what you're gonna do is you're gonna decide, uh, do, and,
and by the way, guys, open claw built this, okay?
This is called a soul builder.
And this creates your personality for open claw. Okay?
So you can do a quick start, which is three questions.
You can do a CEO mo, which is six questions,
or you can do a deep dive and it's just gonna go through
and it's gonna understand
what your goals and objectives are.
And then it's gonna give you a file.
And as soon as we install open claw for you,
and we're gonna do it for free, you're gonna be able
to install that file and it's gonna know what your goals
and objectives are, and it's gonna create its own
personality and it's gonna understand your personality.
Does that make sense to you guys?
So people are learning to create these apps
and everything else, but, uh, here's what I'm gonna do.
Let me just do this real fast.
Uh, I'm gonna come over here
and I'm just gonna say this, um,
yeah, create, actually, let me just try to do this.
Watch this guys. So I'm gonna come off camera real fast
and then I'll, I'll, I'll show it to you again.
So I'm just gonna go into that telegram
and uh, lemme get in the right room.
Uh, I'm in this one. Yeah, I'm gonna press it once.
Hey, can you create a pop link and use Chad nicely.com.
All right. Now I'm gonna share my screen again,
and I'm gonna show you guys very, very simple demo.
Okay? So, uh, you can see here's the audio
and if I close this up here, uh, you're gonna see
that it's typing right now, okay?
And it's gonna ask me, got it.
Creating a pop link with Chad i.com. What's the destination?
And I'm gonna go ahead and say this for destination,
and I'm gonna say, uh, you create the slug.
Always memorize that. Okay?
So it's, it's, it's training right now.
It's learning from me, right? So now watch this.
It's gonna create a pop link.
And I, by the way, everything that I said here, it read
and, and you guys will learn how to set all this up.
It doesn't come like that. You have to, we, we install all
that for you, okay?
So we not only install, uh, all of the,
the models for you, we install it to
where you can just talk to this thing.
Um, we have it to where it has its own email address.
Uh, we set it up to where you can, uh, deploy apps
through a repository
and through, this is like a public app, right?
Uh, we do all of these things, okay?
So you see it's got it up, uh, memorizing.
I create the slug for Soul Builder updating.
Now, all right, now, if I hadn't asked it to, uh, memorize
that, it probably doesn't know.
So I'm gonna say this. I'm gonna say, where is my link?
My goal, guys, is to get this thing where it's
so trained, okay?
I want my pop link.
Remember, I get this thing where it's so trained
that I hardly ever talk to it.
Most of the time it just runs on Aron job. All right?
Um, and while this is, uh, doing this,
lemme see if I could show you this over here.
Yeah. So this is the app that we started building today.
And, uh, there, there's your, here's your, um, pop link.
Everybody's seen this. Usually it
just gives it to me right away.
I think it's 'cause I told it to memorize it.
So I'm gonna go ahead and, and put
that in the chat, alright?
And, and that let me know if that opens up.
The Soul Builder guys
did it.
Let me see if it opens for you guys.
Uh, I'm not seeing it yet.
If you click that, oh, you know what?
I put it in the wrong chat. Hold on a minute.
Send it to everyone. There you go. Alright.
Is that opening for you guys? So you can go through that.
That's gonna give you a memory file. Save that memory file.
You're gonna need it over the next few days.
Um, but at the same time, I'm not done with this yet
'cause I kind of burned out on the call this morning.
But you can see that it went
and created this software for itself and it took a video
and it went and created these, uh, little clips.
And now the next thing is we're sending it to a social media
platform that will sate it out to Facebook, Instagram,
TikTok, all that other stuff.
Are you guys seeing this? It went
and built its own software
to be able to manage that process.
So I told it, look, when you cut the clip, uh, I want you
to let me know when it's done
and I want you to put it in here.
And then I will mark it approved.
And then the minute I mark it approved, it will go
to the approved section over here, okay?
And then once it's marked approved, then you can go ahead
and send it to the platforms to go to TikTok,
Instagram, Facebook.
So it already published this one right here, 10 sessions.
Is there anybody blown away with this right now,
you're not gonna wanna use Opus Clips.
And the reason why is 'cause you won't be able
to get an API, but we found a solution for
that today on the call, right?
So let me try something else.
Uh, if I look at Vimeo, hold on.
Let me, let me, let me do something
that's gonna blow you guys' mine.
And, and I'm just playing right now guys,
'cause I am so burned out after today's call.
Uh, but let me see if the, uh,
replay from today is available.
Hold on, let me see if it's up. Okay, it is up.
All right. So hold on a minute.
Let me name this thing real quick so that it's not confused
'cause I have the wrong name.
Okay? And I'm gonna call it, uh, day 13, I think.
So let's see if we go into course
sprout@dotcoursesprout.com.
Okay? So, uh, not this one, hold on. That's Nick's account.
I don't wanna do that one. Let me see.
Yeah. Okay, so let's see if I can over here.
App course routes. Nope, still Nick's account.
Dang it, Nick, hold on a second. Let's try this one
course.
Okay, so, um, actually I could have gone from the front end.
I told you guys, I'm super tired. All right, members.
Okay, so check this out.
So I'm gonna go over here to, uh, this area here. Okay?
So this is the, this is the open cloth shadow intensive.
And, uh, this is, this is
where we will put you when you're ready to do this thing.
Okay? I'm gonna go to the replays and,
and these are all the replays that we've done.
I have not missed a single day,
even though I've been sick and everything else.
So this was day 12. All right?
So now I understand that we just did day 13 today. Okay?
So here's what I'm gonna do.
This is the link right here that's on Vimeo.
Are you guys seeing this? So
what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna come over here
and I'm gonna go like this.
I'm gonna say, uh, let's do this one.
I'm gonna say four slash replay. Okay?
Now let's see what happens. Let's wait
for it to type up here.
And, and the reason why I don't always see the saying go
bling, bling bling is,
'cause I told it, don't, don't notify me every 10 seconds,
just give me the summary, okay?
And let's see if it's gonna come in. Am I in the right room?
Hello? Let's go.
I'm on a call four slash replay.
All right, there it goes. Okay.
Hey, Chad, we left off with a visitor automation.
Uh, I want you, okay, let's try it.
It's gonna catch up here.
Okay, so I did,
I did this short command slash replay.
So somebody was super surprised, um, that, uh,
somebody was super surprised that we got it to work
with pop links and everything else.
No, we've got it to work with everything.
I want you to grab, uh,
today's replay.
Okay? So let's see what it does.
And it's still, it's still confused
because we're right in the middle of this build out.
We haven't, we haven't finished training on this,
and now I'm asking it to do something else.
Okay? So let's see if we can do this.
And I know that the video is here,
but here's the thing guys.
I'm not gonna tell it. I'm not gonna give it a video.
URL, okay? I just want it to go into Vimeo.
I want it to grab the video itself.
And then what I want it to do is I want it
to go add it to Course Sprout.
And I want to take the transcript, create the lessons,
create the description, and even create the goal block.
Does that make sense? I'll
tell you what's going on with the installs here in a minute.
Um, will,
okay?
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
It is a little slower today.
Uh, I don't, I don't know why that is, but we'll see.
It could be my internet too. I can see it.
Type it on the phone. All right,
come on, Pacino, you're making me look bad.
Here's what you don't know, guys.
Um, I should have probably told it not to kill the detail
'cause you guys probably would be seeing where it's saying,
okay, let me go into Vimeo.
Okay? I found it. Yep, here it is.
Let me grab the transcript.
It's probably doing everything all at once.
And, and when I'm working by myself,
this is what I like to have.
Like, I don't wanna hear ding, ding, ding, ding, ding, ding,
ding, ding, ding, right?
Um, so let's see if we can get this.
And then if we're lucky, maybe g will have this one
connected too and we can talk over here.
All right, there we go. So yeah, see what it's doing.
Let me find today's recording on Vimeo.
Found it Open Cloud day, shadow 13, submitting, oh,
don't submit it to visitor.
Hold on, you are confused.
I want you to do four slash replay
and create the lesson in course Sprout.
Remember, it's confused and it's probably my fault, guys.
I didn't finish what we were building on the earlier call
and now it's super, super confused.
So what it just did, just so you guys know,
lemme see if I can find it.
Uh, yeah, if I open this up over here, it just
sent that video over here.
Do you guys see this? This is
what we trained it to do today.
We trained it to go into Vimeo, grab the video,
send it over here, and now it's cutting it up into pieces.
Are you guys seeing that? All right,
so let's see if we can fix it.
All right, just started processing for three hours.
I'm telling you right now, for a three hour workshop,
it would probably grab about 30 short
form videos outta that.
And the reason why I know that is
because we took a six minute video
and it made nine short form videos, right?
So a three hour video, oh, I don't even know
how many clips it would make.
And it's ready to send out everywhere, right?
Um, alright, so let's see if we can get it to do this.
Let's see if I can fix this.
And it should do the same thing. Yo, you're right.
The course Sprout replay workflow, not visitor clipping.
Let me kill that visitor process and do this correctly.
Course Sprout replay video, open Claw Day 13,
already public, got the transcript,
let me read it to the lesson.
Great. Got the content created in lesson, in course Sprout.
Now lesson created. Now adding the goal block
done lesson created in course Sprout Day 13.
Did you guys see that just now? Yes or no?
How many of you're looking at this going, holy crap.
So when I tell you that this thing is creating pop links,
it's creating courses, it's creating articles, it's,
it's doing all of this inside of our software guys, all
of it, right?
And so what we're doing in the workshops is we're actually
teaching people how to create this stuff,
and then we're just giving them the skills
where they don't even have to, uh, go out there
and teach people how to do this.
So now let's go see if we can find, we had, uh,
day 12, let's reload it.
It, and let's see what we got. There it is.
Day 13, team concerns and AI integration.
Uh, but it didn't load the video. Hold on a second.
That's the first time I've seen it not do that.
So you're gonna see it fix itself, right?
Uh, I don't see the video.
Now this brings up a very valid point, okay?
Uh, we have to make sure that
somebody is there for a while, making sure
that everything goes smooth.
So what I'm telling the team, what I'm telling everybody
is that you are a manager of ai, okay?
Your, your job is not threatened,
but you will no longer build pages.
You will no longer load replays,
you will no longer write emails,
you will not do any of those things.
Instead, you will be the one instructing
AI and checking its work.
Does that make sense to everybody?
And that's the opportunity.
And what's so incredible about this is we're gonna go back
to the days where you're gonna have a developer
that you're gonna pay 250 bucks a month.
And we're gonna go back to the days
where you're gonna have a VA
that you are paying a dollar an hour.
How many of you can see that coming? Yes or no?
All right, let's come over here and let's see it.
Let's see how it did reload.
Okay, hold on a second. Day 13. Oh, it cloned it.
So I'll tell it to fix it.
But there's a video, there's a replay summary
for the lesson topics covered, and it even went
and wrote the goal block.
Now, I don't like how it formatted the goal block,
and these are all things that we have to work and teach it.
I don't like your formatting
of the goal block.
You can do better and add more to it. Yeah.
All right. So things that have to be perfected, okay?
But I'm gonna tell you right now, yes, you're correct.
Open Claw is a team of VAs
and Open.
So here's, here's what happens, guys. Okay?
When you go through that SOUL file,
did everybody get that Soul file today?
When you go through that Soul file, all right,
it's gonna help you understand who you are, okay?
It's gonna help the AI understand who you are, all right?
I also have a process,
and I'm gonna teach you where you are gonna onboard,
um, with this ai, okay?
You're gonna onboard on Open Claw.
It's gonna know exactly who you are.
Once it knows who you are, you start training it on
what it needs to do in your business.
It could be going into JB Zoo, finding an offer,
writing emails, looking at the sales pages, all that stuff.
Whatever it is, finding leads for Brian's deal.
Like whatever it is, it doesn't matter to me, okay?
Once it starts to understand your process,
and once you start to train it
and it's going good, then you are going
to set it up on what's called a Quran job,
where it runs automatically at certain times.
Alright? Now, at that point, you start
to change your language and you start to say, you know what?
You are doing a great job.
I really feel like you understand my company.
So I want you to be more proactive.
In other words, I don't want you to bother me
for little errors.
I don't want you to bother me for, uh, you know,
this page in the load or whatever.
I want you to fix things. You are now the CEO
and I want you to think like a CEO.
And I want you to be proactive,
and I want you to look for loopholes in the business.
I want you to tell me what we can do to make more money,
make more profits, be more productive, be more streamlined.
You are a CEO.
The only thing that I would request is if it's any decisions
that come down to money
or finances, I am the president that you answer to.
Does that make sense? Have the chat.
Let me know if you guys are getting this.
And so what happens is this thing starts to run you,
this thing runs all the VAs underneath it.
And check this out.
This thing starts to run your human team.
And what we did was this, because I have a team
and I'm keeping my team, except the people I've let go this
week, uh, we've set up a dedicated
zoom meeting called Team Call.
And that call is automatically recorded.
And that bot knows that when that call's over,
go grab the transcript, look at the transcript,
we have a call in the morning, call in the evening,
and the call in the morning
is where we have the assignments.
The call in the evening is when, uh, everybody says, here's
what I got done, here's what I didn't get done.
And you need to go through
and figure out, okay, G did this, pne did this, copy,
did this, da da da da da da.
Our, and then what I want you to do is I want you
to update your own Trello board.
And so you need to move the pieces who got done what,
what still needs to get done.
So the next day you're gonna tell us exactly what we need
to do, folks, that's a CEO.
Does that make sense? Is there, now how many
of you have been ignoring this?
And you're going, okay, not the brightest move,
not the smartest thing, right?
You don't want to ignore this.
You don't wanna get behind this.
Now, if you're a part of this class,
have you been a part of this workshop?
Have we made it easy for you? Have we made it non-techie?
Have we done our best?
We still had to restart servers and stuff like that,
but I, I've been doing everything I can where we're able
to use chat GPT, and, and we're able to use Clon if we want,
or perplexity or whatever.
And I, I've done everything I can
to take the techie outta this
and make it super, super easy for you guys.
Okay? So what you wanna do is go through that soul file,
and probably this weekend I'll put this together.
I'm super tired, but I'm super excited at the same
time to do this for you guys.
'cause I know it's gonna be, um, uh, just a, a,
a big deal in in people's lives.
Uh, let me see if I can, um, let me, let me tell it
to fix itself over here.
Uh, yeah,
make sure you delete the extra one.
It knows it too. So I'll just say, yeah, clean it up.
Clean it up,
but, uh, you don't need
my permission.
All right? So it's gonna go
delete that extra one.
Okay? Let's see if it does it.
All right, come on now
on it, clean it up now, no delete endpoint.
Use your browser cleanup.
Okay, so it says, look on it right now.
No delete endpoint. Oh, you can delete it.
You have the endpoint. It has to learn these things, guys.
And remember,
remember this, AI is the worst it's ever gonna be today.
Don't forget that AI is the worst it's ever going
to be today, okay?
I know it can delete it, but it's okay.
I'm not gonna sit here and fight with it.
What I do wanna show you is kind of,
um, how this is gonna work.
So, uh, when you get access to the area,
okay, uh, you go through this initial, let me go over here.
Uh, you go through this initial process
of securing your VPS.
Okay? So what I did was I went
and locked down about 350
servers, okay?
And it was kind of like first come, first serve basis,
and we got bombarded with people that were, uh,
doing the steps like over and over and over and over
and over and over and over, right?
So, um, what we've done now, guys, uh, most
of the people are paying for a server
that's 24 bucks a month.
Uh, we've gone
and set up something that's gonna be a lot cheaper,
a lot easier to use, uh,
and I plan on rolling that out next week so
that we can take care of as many people as we want to.
All right? So I've got a solution for you. All right?
So you'll still do the same thing.
You'll set this up on a box.
Uh, you'll go get your Claude API key.
You wanna start with Claude, and then you submit your form
and then our team goes and does the build out.
Alright? So that process will be a little bit simplified,
but you're still gonna do this onboarding process
where we show you that you're gonna go set up your audio
files, uh, you're gonna create your profile.
You're gonna set up your agent email,
you're gonna set up your telegram,
and then for you guys, all of your titanium,
API keys, all of your software, you are gonna go
and feed, uh, all of your,
your keys to open claw.
Does that make sense? And then once you've done that, uh, I,
I can kind of show you how this works
once you're all set up.
It looks like this, okay?
You come over here and you're gonna remote into your VPS
and you only have to do this till you get telegram set up.
And then what happens is you just, we created this process,
you're just gonna, uh, walk in.
So this is like all of your stuff
that you set up during the membership.
You're just gonna go through it.
You're gonna copy your API key, right?
And you're gonna go back over
to the onboarding process, okay?
If chat will shut up, go back to the onboarding process.
Hold on, let me just do this. There we go.
Right here, right? So I missed it.
Look, so, so all you do, there's no techie.
You just paste your API key.
And then once you do that, it says, congrats,
I've now installed all of the Claude models.
There's nothing else you need to do next.
You're gonna per, you're gonna paste your personal
profile, right?
So saying, what's your name, right?
So you're gonna come over here,
you're gonna tell it your name, and then you're gonna go
and you're gonna paste your profile that I teach you how
to do with Chad GBT.
And once you do that, it says, thanks Chad.
I'll be saving this information in my memory
and reviewing it after we finish this onboarding process.
Next it says, enter your, uh, whisper API key. Okay?
So you go ahead and do that, all right?
And so now your whisper API key is now installed,
and that gives you the ability to do audio next.
It can take control of your browser.
So what you gotta do is you gotta go get the Chrome
extension, right?
So it's gonna install the Chrome extension.
Congrats, I've downloaded the Chrome extension.
Next you're gonna go ahead and put your telegram token.
The members area shows you how to get a telegram token.
So you paste your telegram token just like this.
And then there's this little process you gotta get
through while it pairs everything together.
And it's gonna say, here's your pairing id.
And then you come back over to your bot,
you paste it here, right?
And next you're gonna go set up your agent email address.
And this allows you to go
and, um, uh, your bot can now send out email,
you can forward email, it can,
it can do drafts, whatever you want it to do.
So you go over here, you put your API key in there, right?
Just like this. And then you put your email address there
and it says, congrats.
Now I set up my email. Now I can send
and receive emails on your behalf.
We'll be using it in the very near future.
Now we can go and install memory, right?
So step, that's step number seven, right?
And then once you install the memory, it says, I'll finish,
I'll now be able to handle your data,
projects and skills more efficiently.
Next we have the titanium integration.
So you come over here and you're gonna grab all
of your API keys
for member Letterman global control
course Sprout page, prout.
You paste them in there and it says, okay, uh, then it goes
through and it's gonna grab all of your API keys.
Congrats. I've now added API keys
for Member Letterman global control course route.
Step nine, the morning greetings.
I'd love to start each day off on a positive note.
Is there anything you can think of?
I'd like to tell you about the priorities.
Any tasks you have, anything that's scheduled.
The top 30 priorities for the day. Motivational quote.
A series of videos, right? So you say, okay, good.
And it's gonna say, all right, well, what time say,
all right, well, how about eight 30, whatever, right?
So then it says, fantastic,
I'll greet you at eight o'clock every day.
Next step number 10, what about an evening greeting?
I'd like to tell you about the task I completed.
Check in, tell you how I did for the day.
Anything else you can think of, right?
And so then it asks you, what time is that?
Now look at everything we did, guys.
And what I want you to do is I want you
to go hop on Facebook when you're done
and look at everybody else
that's still trying to get it installed.
Because our onboarding process that we customly,
we personally coded, sets up your claw key,
set up your personal key, set up your whisper key,
your browser extension, your telegram, your agent email,
your memory system, all the titanium keys,
the morning greeting, the evening greetings, all done.
You guys got it
On a scale of one out of
10, how many of you get this right now?
Now, here's what's gonna blow your mind. You ready for this?
If I look at, somebody showed this the other day, right?
If I come over here, if I look at App Sumo
and somewhere over here, they have something called
Services Services.
Where is it at? They moved it. Maybe they took it down.
I don't know. But they have something called services.
Guess how much they were doing?
Just the install for, can anybody guess
just the install alone?
Can anybody guess? I don't see where it went.
I do not see where it went. New arrivals.
Yeah, I don't know what they did with it,
but $1,500, $1,500
to do what I am doing for free.
I honestly don't know what they did with it services.
Hold on. There's one, uh, let's see if it's over here.
Yeah, that's kind of odd. I wonder why they got rid of it.
They, they probably got bashed on.
'cause it was a ridiculous, ridiculous price.
And, uh, people went back
and they said, Chad's doing it for free.
And that's the reason why everybody's p****d off at me.
They're like, you're taking
all the opportunity away from us.
I'm like, why? You're not actually
doing it yourself anyways.
Why do you care? I've had arguments with
so many JVs, so many partners.
I'm like, it don't matter to me, right?
I'm gonna take care of my members, right?
You wanna go out there and charge 9 97, uh,
you know, $1,500.
We charge 4 97 for the workshop for two weeks plus the, um,
install, plus the whole onboarding.
And I feel like that's a pretty good price when these other
guys are charging three times the price, right?
So I missed a free opportunity.
You didn't, it's coming back up.
So I want everybody to watch your email this morning,
or I'm sorry, not this morning, this weekend.
Uh, 'cause I'm gonna give you access to that membership.
You'll go through the steps.
It'll be this weekend or Monday, I gotta check in
with the team right after this call.
You'll go through the steps, uh,
and then you'll get access to the members area.
You'll set up your VPS and everything else.
And then if you want to attend the second workshop again,
uh, you can, and we're gonna go
through the same exact process
and you guys are gonna learn how to do everything.
Does that make sense? Does everybody get this?
So you haven't missed the opportunity at all? Not at all.
Now, this will not last forever, okay?
I'm gonna get back on newsletters, I promise you.
And, and we're still updating everything all the time.
I've still got my team and everything else right now.
This is really, really important. Does that make sense?
This stuff is really, really important, okay?
Um, and even if you don't have a 4, 9, 7, whatever,
I'll work at a payment plan, whatever.
It's, it's not so much the money.
Guys, I want you to invest in yourself.
Let me tell you a secret outta 3000 people
that we talked to.
Do you know how many people Ashley took us
up on the free install?
We, we personally messaged over 3000 people
free install, free on.
Do you know how many people took us up on that?
Considering that there was a hundred plus in the mastermind,
plus another 30 that bought the intensive whatever it was.
Do you know it was less than 200 people.
Less than 200 people did the two steps when I know
for a fact we messaged over 3000 people.
Do you understand? Like nobody values
what's given away for free.
So I want you to invest in it so
that you show up every single day.
My people, believe it or not,
have been showing up every single day.
My numbers have been consistent every single day.
They've been showing up every single day.
And just to kind of show you,
because I asked him, uh, to quote some
or to, um, leave a comment on my wall today just
so you guys can kind of see this right now.
So, you know how important this is.
These comments over here, right?
Where I asked them if you were on the, uh,
so far there's 20 comments, but,
but I mean, if I look at the newest ones, like, look what,
look at what people are saying, right?
Sherry says, 10 out of 10,
I never would've gotten off the ground without Chad.
Step by step guidance, knowing my setup is secure on a VPS
gives me total peace.
And that foundation means everything.
Chad and his team are right there in the trenches
with us finding the bugs before we hit them
and keeping the frustration low.
And when you do get stuck,
the team is always there to help you through it.
My biggest light bulb moment was watching Open Claw generate
a complete published writing newsletter article
inside a Letterman, full text images without me lifting a
finger for someone running a weekly newsletter.
That's an absolute game changer. We're just getting started.
See this? Robert said, I give these last 14 days.
This all the 10, this worktop workshop didn't just teach me
new, it completely shifted the way I
look at how my business runs.
My biggest light bulb moment was realizing
how much I've been carrying on my own.
That open claw now can handle with precision, consistency
and zero hesitation.
Chad, you didn't just show us the tech, you showed us
what becomes possible when you actually put it
to work, being this intensive.
Felt like stepping into the future while everyone else is
still trying to figure out what AI even is.
I'm walking outta this with clarity, momentum
and a whole new level of confidence.
Truly grateful for the experience that was Next level.
Are, are you guys seeing this right now?
So I'm not gonna read every single one,
but I wanna leave you with this.
Can you guys agree everybody
that ignored this the first time,
can you guys type in the chat?
I agree that this is not something that you should ignore.
It is not something you should ignore. Yeah.
So we set up the VPS and we install it.
If you wanna go through all the stuff that we did
with the API keys
and everything else, uh, we do that manually, right?
So if you wanna do that, that's where it costs.
And you also get the workshop with it, right?
And like I said,
we'll set up whatever, payment plan, whatever.
I just really, uh,
I just really want you guys investing in it.
I want you showing up every day
and, uh, not putting this off.
This is not something you can put off. Does that make sense?
Is everybody starting to get this?
Everybody's starting to get this. Yeah. All right.
Is there any safety issues? There's tons of safety issues.
Hell yeah, there's safety issues.
This thing has arms, legs, eyes and ears.
Yeah, there's safety issues. That's why we put it in a box.
If the damn thing breaks, it breaks in the box.
I trust it as far as I can throw it.
You don't put this on your personal computer,
you don't give it a credit card, you don't give it a bank,
you don't give it access to Gmail.
You don't give it anything important guys.
It thinks for itself, especially when you say it's a CEO,
it thinks for itself.
Do you understand? You want it to think for itself,
but not in your personal system.
You don't give it access to anything important.
Yeah, there's huge, huge problems.
There's also, um, you know, hubs
where you can download what are called skills.
The hubs are all infected.
People are downloading those skills
and they're going on, you know,
YouTube, go download this skill.
It's incredible. Meanwhile,
all these nasty little files are going into the open claw
and taking over the open claw
and getting super, super malicious and making posts
and yeah, there's huge nightmares with it.
So let's be safe. I'm sure everybody would agree.
Yeah, the install's free. I'm sure everybody would agree.
Yeah, that I've been safe. I've been very, very safe.
Extremely safe. Now that doesn't mean
that we're not tying it into page proud and pop links and GC
and pulling contacts and firing tags and writing articles.
Of course we are. And what I'm teaching people is
to go out there and share that with the world.
'cause it's a shiny object right now,
but so what if it creates an ex if it creates an extra
lesson today, like it did.
So what? Go delete it. You know what I mean?
Like, you're safe, you're safe, you're absolutely safe.
And when we do the install
and everything, we make sure all the
security protocols are in place.
Like you're safe.
Like we were the first ones to say,
do not install this on your personal system.
Okay? Is, does everybody feel good about that?
Now you don't put it on your system.
I, you know, people are like, oh, I'm gonna put it on.
I'm gonna go spend $10,000 on a little app, mini whatever.
You freaking idiot. Why would you do that?
Why would you go spend $10,000 on an app mini
and you know nothing about this, guys,
I'm gonna tell you right now, nobody
is running this thing like we are ha has anybody seen
anybody doing a fraction of what we're doing?
Anybody at all out there? In any of the groups?
There's all these, the freaking open claw groups
and everything, and do you see anybody doing anything?
No. Absolutely. Freaking not. They're talking a lot.
They're making their posts.
Here's 12 things you can do with open Claw.
And then they got the 12 things in the comment.
Nobody's doing it. We're doing it.
We are doing it.
So the question is, where do you install it?
Then you install it,
what's called a virtual private server, A VPS.
And so with a VPS, I can go to remote desktop
and I can enter an IP address and I log in
and I'm actually inside of a different computer.
Yeah, so you're safe, you're safe.
It doesn't have access to files there, nothing.
We give it API keys that it works with.
You know, there's, there's some keys.
Like today we, we tapped into
that video service and we could use that.
We typed into, uh, tapped into a social media platform.
We can use that. Uh, I want you guys
to know something else too, you guys, as my core audience.
Uh, I, I am, uh, extremely, uh, excited
to have you be a part of my world,
especially for the next 18 months.
We are going to build out a lot of apps, a lot of apps
that you see being sold out there.
We're already building them. Here's the thing,
I'm gonna keep adding them to gc.
I'm not going to charge anybody.
I have no desire to turn around
and try to make money off something
that took my team two days.
Instead, I'll use it to, um, uh,
build a big audience and teach my people how to do it.
Now, I'll teach you how to sell it.
I'll teach you how to grow a,
that's not how we make our money.
We make our money from our mastermind
and from our core software and our platinum offers
and our advance and workshops and stuff like that, right?
So, uh, it's, it's gonna be incredible.
One of 'em is gonna be our lead finder
where you're gonna be able to say, okay, I wanna, uh,
pull business owners from Summerland.
It'll pull the business owners,
it'll mail out the business owners.
You can add 'em to gc, put 'em in a workflow, uh, all all
that crazy stuff, all the mind mapping stuff,
all the little agents, like all
that software is really easy for us to build.
I'm not here to sell it.
I'm not gonna put you on a webinar
and say, you can buy this.
And I'm not, I'm just not gonna do it, guys.
I'm not gonna do it. Not everything's about money, right?
Give, give, sell, give, give, sell, give, give,
sell, give, give, sell.
And when I sell, we do good,
but most of the time I'm giving make sense?
Does that make sense? Yeah, I know.
I said the call will last an hour. I'm sorry.
I get too excited. Look man, I like being with you guys.
I love my team too. Hold on a minute. Is my team here?
Uh, I, I love my team too, but they put me to work.
You guys don't put me to work.
I just get to share the, the good news with you guys, right?
So, um, do me a favor, watch your mail right now. Okay?
I got 3000 active clickers. I usually have 300 clickers.
Guys. What we're doing with our software is incredible.
And by the way, let me leave you at this too.
Um, we have discovered this week
that autoresponders are scams,
autoresponders are scams.
Now, I first realized
that when I logged in the next account,
'cause I haven't had an autoresponder for a while,
I logged in active campaign
and, uh, there was 45,000, 45,000,
uh, subscribers, okay?
And, uh, there's 70,000.
He was paying, uh, $1,500 a month.
And I open up the email
and I'm like, well, you're mailing 40,000,
you got a hundred clicks, that's not very good.
He goes, no. I said, no, it's not good.
And what they're doing is they're charging
for the 70,000 contacts.
Does that make sense? They're charging for 70,000 contacts.
He's reaching maybe, maybe 7,000 people
and getting a hundred clicks.
They're charging for the number of contacts.
Our system is so good
because it does something autoresponder aren't gonna do.
Our system tells you who your green people are,
who your active people are, who your active clickers are,
who your active openers are.
Then it tells you who is inactive,
and then it tells you who's dead.
And so all you do is focus on the green
and then you reengage the other people.
If you're just focusing on the green guys.
And, and the reason why I win every single promo out there
and everything else is because of
what I'm about to tell you.
If you just focus on the green, then your, uh, actual costs
for mailing are nothing.
Does that make sense? If you don't understand all this
stuff, you will,
'cause we're gonna start focusing on this stuff.
You wanna know why? Because, uh, let me try this right now.
Hold on a second. Uh,
gimme just a minute right here.
Watch this and then I will close the call.
I, I i I will after this, right?
I'm gonna say forward slash Actually,
let me, let me go like this.
Check this out right here. Telegram.
Where'd to go? Telegram, there it is.
I'm not used to Telegram. Okay, so here we go.
I'm gonna open up my bot and I'm gonna press it
and let's see, can I just send it?
I got this little window open. Okay, there we go.
Okay. It won't let me, oh, 'cause I'm in help mode, okay?
Forward slash
email, all right.
What it's gonna do is gonna ask me, it's gonna say,
what do you wanna write an email on?
I'm gonna say, open claw is the greatest thing to ever hit.
Uh, is the greatest technology ever to hit our planet?
Okay, so, uh, hold on a second.
Lemme make sure, uh, transcription got garbled.
Maybe I said it too fast.
So let's try it like this
and lemme see if I can share my screen.
Watch this, this, if, if we can get this demo to work, guys,
and this is where I'll leave it.
This will blow your mind.
Okay, so here's what I just wrote right here.
Uh, Pacino, uh, four slash email.
What's the email about? Um,
open Claw is the greatest AI technology
ever to hit the planet.
All right? That's it. Okay, let's watch what it does.
And remember, it could be muffled with everything
that we've been doing today, okay?
Uh, it's good that you've recovered.
I haven't recovered completely, Pete, but I'm getting there.
Here's your email. This changes everything.
I'm not one to hype things up for the sake of it,
but open claw, this is different.
This is the most powerful AI technology I've ever used
and I'm tried them all.
Here's what matters. Most AI tools, uh, give you answers.
Open cloud gives you an employee, one that works 24 7,
never complains, learns your business,
and gets smarter every single day.
It connects to your software, it automat your workflows,
it handles your emails, your content,
your social media, CRM, all of it.
And the best part is you.
You don't need to be technical to use it.
I've been teaching this to my students
and the results have been incredible.
People are getting hours back in their day.
Businesses are running smoother. Revenue's going up.
If you're not using Open Claw yet,
you're leaving money on the table.
Uh, what is the link?
Chad nicely.com/open claw.
All right, now it knows that that's a pop link. Why?
'cause it has access to the pop links.
Are you guys seeing this right now?
I wanna make sure everybody is seeing this right now, right?
Okay, so now it's saying, uh, send this test.
I'll say, sure, send the test
so it knows to send a test to see nicely.
thirty2@gmail.com, right?
So once I get the test, I can also tell it
to reengage.
Okay? So let me see.
See nicely 32. I haven't seen it yet.
There's that one. I saw the Friday Tech call it sent
out, but let's see.
All inbox. Nope, nothing yet.
This is the same issue from the health checks.
Need to refresh manually, log in API generate, uh,
want me to send a different method?
Try again. I haven't seen that one before.
This stuff will happen for a little while, guys.
Um, but it'll, it, the cool thing about this,
it will usually fix itself
and I need to ask it what model it's on to
because I want to be on a model that's pennies on the dollar
because I feel like it does a better job.
So watch, let me show you this. What model are you on?
Okay, it's on sonnet 4.5, go to Kimmy 2.5.
This is how you change AI models.
And Kimmy 2.5 is
pennies on the dollar.
Like I think it was Josh today that mentioned he did a ton
of stuff yesterday and it cost him 4 cents, right?
So that's the one that you want to be on.
Switch to Kimmy 2.5.
Uh, okay, try again with the API.
It might be some I need to have, uh, G look into,
but the thing is, it just wrote the email
and everything, so I know it has access to the API.
Okay? And while it's doing that, look over here,
uh, where'd telegram go?
I, uh, the key.
Okay, I'll do that demo again soon.
But let me see what's happening over here. Uh, look at that.
Have you guys is pulling your chat? Id? Hi bot. Hi bot.
Are you there? Hi G I'm here. What can I help you with?
Are you guys seeing this right now?
They're setting up this bot to work with this group.
Now, um, here's the crazy thing.
I wanted to make sure that I spend
some time with you guys today.
We have 10 VIP accounts we have to set up this weekend.
Over 10. Over 10, all right?
So, uh, I am gonna keep it at an hour and a half for reels.
Uh, watch your guys' emails.
I'm gonna send those bridge pages out, okay?
So that you guys can watch, um, this stuff happening.
Uh, and then, uh, I will let you know as soon as
that server is set up so
that we can do the VPS for you again.
And then you guys can go through the members area
and you're gonna be ready for this workshop.
Does that work? Does that work for everybody?
Okay, good. Lemme just check in.
Did you guys get a lot of value on the call?
Look, look at what it, uh, hold on. I'll leave you at this.
Look what it's saying over here.
Look at these, these guys are are, are freaking out.
Look, uh, I'm here for the whole group.
Happy to help whenever anyone needs me. You guys see that?
So g has been working that this whole call, um, there,
there's still definitely some techie stuff that has
to happen to make that happen,
but wow, how incredible is that
to have your whole team in there talking, right?
Alright guys, I will keep you posted. Thank you.
Thank you, thank you. I appreciate it.
We'll get the replay out. We should be
back on track next week.
Um, and uh, we'll, we'll be ready for 2.0. It'll be good.
Uh, don't let anybody get in your head. We're safe.
Trust me, you're in good hands. It's gonna be incredible.
It's gonna change everything for you.
Alright, thank you so much guys,
and I'll talk to you real soon.
Bye-bye.